>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington, DC.
>> Tomoko Steen: Welcome, everyone.
I'm Tomoko Steen at Science,
Technology and Business Division.
Today's event is cosponsored
with Office of Health Services.
And this is a topic really
everyone is concerned about because,
you know, outbreak in hospitals,
even NIH, and also the food,
a lot of antibiotics used in food.
So Dr. Price is going to talk about
several issues really concerned now.
And the UN had a meeting just
recently, and that's because,
you know, it's going
to be out-of-hand.
So it's a worldwide concern.
Today's speaker, Dr. Price,
is director of Antibiotic
Resistance Action Center,
and professor of George
Washington University's Department
of Environmental and
Occupational Health
at the Milken Institute
School of Public Health.
And he's also the director of
the Center for Macrobiotics
and Human Health at Translation
Genomics Research Institute.
So this is a nonprofit
based in Arizona.
And Dr. Price did his PhD at Johns
Hopkins University in public health.
So I think it's already a little
bit delayed, so before much adieu,
please join me in welcoming
Professor Price.
>> Lance Price: Thank you.
[ Applause ]
Thank you for the invitation,
and for the introduction;
I appreciate that.
I'm not checking my
e-mail, I just --
[laughter] I want to make sure
I don't go too far over time.
So I think you recognize that this
is the world we live in today,
right, the world between
the freak-out moments.
So this could be applied to,
you know, perhaps gun control
and these horrible school shootings
where, you know, these take place,
we freak out, we demand
action, and then we go back
to our lives until it happens again.
This could also be applied
to weird weather events
and global climate change.
And some have argued that
this applies to superbugs.
So we do hear about superbugs.
They hit the mainstream media, and
we freak out for a little while,
and then we go back to our
busy lives and we expect
that somebody did something
about it, right?
But I would argue that
this is actually
that graph the applies to superbugs.
Because what happens is that these
things hit the mainstream media,
they're circulating, we're hearing
about them, and we expect the CDC
or somebody to do something
about it.
And then it kind of leaves
the media cycle, right?
And we think that they've gone away,
but in fact they're
there, they're still there.
And when the next one comes
out, it's piled on top, right?
And what's happening is that the
medical community is just learning
how to deal with it.
I'm going to learn
how to deal with this.
[ Inaudible Comment ]
Okay, stop.
Thank you.
All right.
So, you know, the medical
communities doctors learn,
they scramble, they reach higher
on those shelves of the antibiotics
and they reach for the
next one, and the next one.
And they get the stool out, and
they reach out for the next one.
But what's happened is that
we are running out of shelves.
So we don't have new antibiotics,
and the bacteria are
continuing to evolve resistance.
And so we keep hearing now about
us moving towards what's called the
"post-antibiotic era" in medicine.
And the World Health Organization
describes this as a time
when even a scraped
knee can be a deadly --
can result in a deadly infection,
because you can get staph aureus
in that scrape, and if we
don't have the antibiotics
to treat the staph aureus infection,
that can get into your
blood and kill you.
A bladder infection that's a
really painful annoyance right now,
can progress to kidney infections.
And once it's in your kidneys,
it can access the blood
and can cause deadly
blood infections.
And so we're moving towards a time
when these really common
infections can be deadly.
And I think -- so this is
not the apocalypse, right,
so it's not the end of
humanity as we know it.
But I don't think it's
overstating it to say that is going
to change our lives dramatically.
It's going to change everything
from what procedures can take place
in the hospital, you know,
can we do that hip surgery,
can we do that bowel surgery,
can we give somebody
chemotherapy that's going to knock
out their immune system for
several months; probably not.
And it's also going to
change the way it feels
to ride public transportation,
or ride that escalator,
and grab that handle and think
about whether you picked
up a superbug or not.
Right; so these superbugs have
many different monikers, right?
You hear about MRSA;
who's heard about MRSA?
MRSA, right, Methicillin-resistant
Staphylococcus aureus.
Kills 11,000 people in the
United States each year.
VRSA is just vancomycin
resistant MRSA, right?
And vancomycin is a crappy drug, but
this is the one we're really afraid
of because that's the
last drug we've got.
VRA, CRA, these are just
different monikers for superbugs.
And these are just basically
disease-causing bacteria
that are resistant to antibiotics,
usually multiple antibiotics,
although we usually refer
to them based on one drug.
And so people ask me
all the time, you know,
"So how does this bacterium
-- " that's a bacterium to me,
"how does a bacterium turn
into a super-bacterium?"
And that's a super bacteria to me.
"How does it go from this to this?"
And it goes from this to
this by changes in the DNA.
So bacteria multiply themselves,
so they don't reproduce sexually;
they just make copies of their DNA,
and then they split from one to two,
and the two become
four, eight, 16, 32.
And each time they do that,
they have to make copies
of four-and-a-half, sometimes,
you know, more millions of bases.
So two, to four, to five million
bases of DNA, Gs, As, Ts, and Cs.
And when they do that, they
can make errors and some
of those errors result
in changes in proteins
that make them resistant
to antibiotics.
So the other thing that they
can do is some bacteria carry
around these extra little
packages of DNA called "plasmids,"
or other elements, and they can
pass these to other bacteria.
So in a single genetic event,
they can pass resistance to six,
seven different antibiotics just
by bumping together
and passing this DNA.
And now what we have
is we have a world war.
We have bacteria that
are already carrying lots
of different resistance genes,
and they're just waiting
for that one last resistance gene
to get that royal flush, right?
And this is what we're really afraid
of, right, we have lots of bacteria
that are one card away
from a royal flush.
And now we know that that last
card is floating around out there.
I'm going to come back
to this later.
So that's happening all
the time in the background,
but most of the time,
that's a dead end.
Right; so these mutations happen,
and then those bacteria fizzle out.
But if you're in an environment
where there are lots of antibiotics,
even one of those mutations
can result
in a rapid evolution
drug resistant bacteria.
So in an environment where
you have lots of drugs,
then the susceptible
bacteria die off --
excuse my sort of South
Park style cartoons,
but these are the best I can draw,
and that resistant one
then goes on to multiply.
So one becomes two -- I skipped
a step, two becomes four,
four becomes eight, et cetera.
And you can go from a single cell
to a billion drug-resistant
bacteria in 24 hours.
So E. Coli can double, can do
these doubling every 30 minutes.
And E. Coli is one of the worst
superbugs that we deal with today.
So you can go from a single superbug
cell to billions in 24 hours.
So there's a lot of confusion
in the mainstream media.
You all are brilliant, so I
probably don't need to say this.
But, you know, the media talks
about people becoming resistant
to antibiotics, but I think it's
really important to make sure
that you understand this, even
though it's a simple concept,
that it's not people that
are becoming resistant
to antibiotics, it's bacteria.
And those are colonizing
us and infecting us,
and those infections
are harder to treat,
it gives doctors fewer choices,
and these result in more
and more deaths every year.
And the CDC conservatively
estimates today
that 23,000 Americans die
each year of superbugs.
And Tom Frieden, the head of the
CDC underscored several times
that this was a conservative
estimate.
It's really difficult to
know whether somebody died
with a drug-resistant infection,
or of a drug-resisted infection
when somebody's already sick.
So understanding that
rapid evolution,
understanding this
relationship underscores the fact
that each time we use antibiotics,
we potentially fuel the
growth of superbugs.
And Stuart Levy, one of my heroes
from Tufts University,
coined this term.
He said antibiotics
are "societal drugs."
So what he was trying
to do was explain
that antibiotics are different
from any other drugs that we use.
And I'd like to start
with a counterexample.
So Tylenol is not a societal drug.
People take Tylenol for headaches.
If you misuse Tylenol,
if you overuse it,
if you use it while you're drinking,
you can get liver damage and die.
People commit suicide, a horrible
suicide using lots of Tylenol.
But it does affect
anybody else's ability
to take Tylenol for a headache.
However, if you misuse antibiotics,
you can drive the bacteria
in your system, in your gut, on
your skin, to become resistant
to antibiotics and you can share
those bacteria with other people,
preventing them from
using those same drugs.
So that's what Stuart
was trying to convey
with this idea of the societal drug.
Now, when you think about
that societal nature,
you have to recognize that
the context and the quantity
of antibiotics that we're
using really matters.
And I think the thing
that people think of most
of the time is this context, right,
you think about the hospital,
and this is where we know there are
a lot of drug-resistant bacteria.
And we know that if these people
are not washing their hands,
and aren't hitting that hand
sanitizer between every patient,
they can become vehicles
for drug-resistant bacteria;
they can spread them around.
And we have to have teams of
people wiping surfaces all the time
to keep those contact
surfaces clean.
So nobody denies that, and nobody
denies that this is too much.
We're using eight million
pounds of active ingredient.
That's not the size
of the pill, right,
that's the active drug inside the
pill; eight million pounds of that
in the united States
in human medicine.
American Medical Association and
the American Academy of Pediatrics,
all these different associations
say, "This is too much.
We need to cut it back.
We're overusing antibiotics."
And why do they say that,
because we're fueling
the growth of superbugs.
And then if you have the
combination of this excessive use
and then poor hygiene, the
doc skips that hand sanitizer,
skips washing the hands, then that's
how we have those horrible hospital
outbreaks to drug-resistant
bacteria.
So that's human medicine.
But I want to talk
about animal production.
So that's the thing I spend
most of my time studying.
And here's the quantity in animal
production in the United States.
This is the most recent number.
And we were hoping it was
going to go down; it went up.
So we're at 34 million
pounds of antibiotics
in food animal production in
the United States each year.
So you can see that that's more than
what we're using in human medicine.
So let's talk about the context.
So that's quantity.
So this is not the context.
This is my imagined
context when I was a kid.
And this was -- did
anybody play with these
when you were a kid; yes, all right.
So you can buy these
on eBay it turns out.
I found the era that I played
with, and I took that photo.
Okay. But this is the way we
actually raise animals today.
So cattle will spend part of their
lives grazing on open pastures,
like my family's ranch in
Central Texas, but they'll end
up on feed lots like this
one; and that's not dirt
that they're standing around on.
Pigs spend their entire lives
in concentrated animal
feeding operations today.
And these are not full-grown pigs.
When they're full grown,
they are snout to tail.
But they are so stressed
out in this environment
that they clip the tails off
because they'll bite them off.
They get very aggressive
under these conditions.
Chickens, up to 100,000
in a single house.
And turkeys are raised like this.
So some people refer to
these as "factory farms."
But as a microbiologist, I
don't see factories making meat,
I see factories making lots
and lots of bacteria, right?
And when you add that magic
ingredient of low levels
of antibiotics, then you have
a factory making superbugs.
And this has been established
with every study that we do
around these factory farms --
or, sorry, around these
industrial farms.
We detect lots and lots of
drug-resistant bacteria.
Now, one of the things that
we use the antibiotics for,
and one of the major things
that we have historically
used antibiotics for,
was to make animals grow faster.
So we give them low
doses of antibiotics.
This was discovered in the 1940s.
Like right after Alexander
Fleming discovered antibiotics,
someone discovered that
giving animals low doses
of antibiotics helps
them grow faster.
We don't really understand.
Probably changing the microbiome;
that is the gut community
of bacteria, passing more
energy onto the animal.
But we don't exactly know how
well it works, and how it works.
But the other justified
use is preventing diseases.
But some of the diseases we're
preventing are what we call
"production diseases," that
is diseases that are occurring
because of the way we're
raising these animals.
So I'll give you a
couple of examples.
So one of the things that we have a
lot of is shipping fever and cattle.
So it turns out that when you raise
animals, you let the animals graze,
you have to then get them to
those feed lots, and you put them
in these trucks to get
them to those feedlots,
and sometimes you're
shipping them for days.
And you stack them
up two layers high.
These are cattle actually in this.
This is what it looks
like when you empty it.
And so it doesn't take
a microbiologist
or an infectious disease doctor
to recognize that this is going
to make these animals sick.
But rather than change
this system --
don't ask me how, maybe
distributing smaller feedlots closer
to the grazing lands.
Instead of changing that, we just
give them all antibiotics right
at that time when we're about
to put them all together
in those fecal wastelands.
So that's one production
disease that we're treating.
Another one is when you switch
these animals that have evolved
to eat grass, and you switch
them to corn and soybean,
they get liver abscesses.
And so rather than
trying to figure out a way
to have them not get liver abscesses
by changing the diet or, you know,
lengthening the time
that we're feeding them,
we give them antibiotics, again
while they're crowded together.
Okay; so here's a problem,
I think in Fisher-Price.
Maybe that's not a problem, but the
public health problem that I want
to describe is that you --
each animals has trillions of
bacteria living in and on it.
So that's not trillions, but I don't
have enough pixels to draw this.
But anyway, the animal has trillions
of bacteria living in and on it.
And when you feed them
antibiotics, you're going to force
that evolutionary process to
take place in those animals.
Ad so the bacterial
become resistant.
And then when you chop up those
animals to make pork chops,
you're going to inevitably
contaminate some of those pork chops
with some of the bacteria from
either the gut of that animal,
or the skin of those animals.
And then those bacteria can then go
on to cause infections in people,
and we get the little frowny faces.
And again, the problems
that I described before,
you're giving physicians
fewer choices
for treating those infections,
and we know that those infections
last longer, and they cost more
to treat, and they
result in more deaths.
So I just wanted to underscore
something because, again,
there's been a lot of
confusion about this issue.
The main concern -- while we are
concerned about traces of drugs
in the meat, it's not the
antibiotics in the meat
that we're most concerned
about, it's drug-resistant --
living infectious,
drug-resistant bacteria
on the meat that's the real
public health challenge.
And so sometimes you'll hear
companies describing how they remove
antibiotics early enough
so there are no drugs
in the meat, so don't worry.
But that doesn't -- the
bacteria don't respond
that quickly to that removal.
And so when you go to
slaughter those animals,
you're going to contaminate
the meat with those bacteria.
Okay; so for years, we -- it turns
out there's been a big argument
about this for years, and I've
been sort of part of this argument,
not as long as people Stuart Levy.
Stuart Levy has been having
this argument for 40 years.
But for years the argument
was framed
around the classic
food-borne pathogens
like salmonella and campylobacter.
I'm sure you've all
heard of salmonella.
Have you heard of campylobacter?
Okay; it turns out that they
are sort of tied number one
and number two in terms
of causing diarrhea
in the United States,
bacterial diarrhea.
And together they cause
about 2.6 million cases
of diarrhea, all right?
And most of that is coming from
contaminated poultry products.
And the CDC estimates
that about 410,000
of these infections are
antibiotic-resistant.
And that resistance can be traced
back to either contemporary
or historic use of antibiotics
in food animal production.
So just to put things in
perspective, that's the population
of Miami getting drug-resistant
food borne infections
in the United States each year.
But not very many people
die of those infections.
So most people who get
diarrhea will have, you know,
they'll be uncomfortable for five
or six days, they'll use a lot
of toilet paper, and
they'll recover.
A thousand people will
not; they die.
It gets into the blood and they die.
But apparently, a thousand
people is not enough
to change policy in
the United States.
So we have to move --
I've been saying for years
that we have to move back.
We need to move beyond the
classic food borne pathogens,
because there's a lot
more than salmonella
and campylobacter in
the food supply.
We need to understand the --
what we call the "colonizing
opportunist pathogens," or COPs.
These are the big killers.
And when you talk to an
infectious disease doc,
they want to know about these guys.
They don't care about
salmonella and campylobacter;
they just don't kill enough people.
So we're not talking
about Andy Griffith there.
We're talking more along the
lines of Harvey Keitel in the
"Bad Lieutenant," you know.
Some of these movie posters really
give it all away, right, "Gambler,
Thief, Junkie, Killer, Cop."
All right; anyway it's
colonizing opportunist pathogens.
These include things like E. Coli,
escherichia intestinal
pathogenic E. Coli,
the kind that causes
bladder infections.
Klebsiella pneumonia; have
you ever heard of KLEB,
klebsiella, a few of you.
So this is a big killer
in the United States.
One of the biggest
superbugs is that klebsiella.
And one of the biggest
superbugs is in E. Coli.
And one of the biggest superbugs
is staph aureus, M R S A, MRSA.
So COPs can live in
or on our bodies.
So staph can live in your
nose, in your throat,
for years without you knowing it.
No symptoms.
You can just be a carrier, and you
can share it with other people.
E. Coli can live in
your gut for decades
and you wouldn't even know it.
It doesn't cause symptoms
until it gets into the bladder,
until it gets into the blood.
And so you can become
this reservoir.
And so these COPs cause what I
like to call "insidious epidemics."
So they can spread globally.
They can get on planes with us.
They get on trains and
boats, and they get on meat,
and they travel the world.
The problem is that they have
asymptomatic colonization.
So these fever monitors in airports
are not going to work, right,
they're not going to
detect these things.
They're silent person-to-person
transmission.
You come home from your
trip to India, or China,
or the United States, and you
bring home drug-resistant bacteria
and share them with your family
members, and no one knows it, right,
until their immune
system is knocked down.
We don't know how long
they can colonize.
We know that they can
be from days to years.
And then it's really difficult
because you can have
animals carry them,
you can have humans carry
them, you can have environment,
water, carrying these bacteria.
So these are really hard to study.
And I like a good challenge,
and so that's what I study.
And this is the machine that I use.
This is the next generation
DNA sequencer.
So now we have sequencers.
We can sequence DNA at a rate --
at a cost that was never
even imaginable before.
We can sequence bacterial
genome millions
of bases for less than $50 today.
When the anthrax letters were
mailed and we did this investigation
on the anthrax letters, it cost
half a million dollars per genome;
half a million dollars
per bacterium.
Today it's $50.
This is changing fast.
And it's changing what we understand
about infections, and it's so fun.
I'll just tell you, I'm a Geek.
Okay; so the way that -- so
what we do is we take the DNA
and then looking at
these little mutations,
we can redraw the family
history of these bacteria.
So if we have bacteria -- so
going back to the anthrax letters,
if we have a letter, and we have a
vial or a flask in a government lab,
and we want to know if these two are
related, we can sequence the DNA,
and we can look for
these little mutations,
and we could see how they're
related to one another.
So we draw these little trees.
And we just have -- and based
on the length of these branches
and what we call these
"common ancestors,"
the little nodes connecting
these guys,
we can redraw the evolutionary
history of this bacteria,
and we can understand how
they're related to one another.
And then we can actually do
something that's called "rooting,"
and we can understand
who is older --
or which nodes are older and
which ones are more derived,
that is, more recent.
And this is so powerful, it's
almost like a time machine.
So we can go back in time.
And we need a time machine for this
because we've been using antibiotics
in animal production
for seven years.
So how much of the drug resistance
that we're dealing with today
in human medicine is due in part
because of antibiotic
use in animal production?
These time machines are
helping us figure this out.
So I'll tell you a little bit
about the work that we're doing
on MRSA first, and then
I'll go onto E. Coli.
So MRSA -- this is
microbiologists like me are weird
so there are stuffed animals.
Have you seen these
giant microbes; yes.
Okay; so there are these
giant microbes teddy bears
that you would hug.
I don't have one.
But if you want to learn about MRSA,
I really recommend Maryn
McKenna's book, "Superbug."
It's a great -- it's actually --
it's a very long title
if you read it.
But I just focus on the
green part, "Superbug."
It's a really, really
well-written book.
It reads like a novel,
but it's a nonfiction.
But if you don't have time for that,
you can just go to the CDC website
and you can learn about the
five Cs of MRSA transmission.
These are the things that we know
lead to the transmission of M R S A.
So crowding, frequent
skin-to-skin contact,
so rubbing up against one
another, compromised skin, so cuts
and abrasions, contaminated
items and surfaces,
and then a general
lack of cleanliness.
The last two seem a
little redundant to me,
but I'm not criticizing the CDC.
Okay. They don't go onto say where
the five Cs are really prevalent,
and I guess you would want to
stay away from those places.
So the five Cs are common --
and locations where the five Cs are
common include schools, dormitories,
military barracks, households,
stay away from those,
correctional facilities,
and daycare centers, right;
so all the places we
kind of hang out, right?
And I think what they're getting
at is that where you have crowding,
where you have people
living close to one another,
you can pass these bacteria along.
But when I see the five Cs, I
don't think about households,
I think about a concentrated
animal feeding operation.
Now you have full-grown pigs.
This is the way they look
when they're full-grown,
just about ready for slaughter.
So this is what we call a
"concentrated animal feeding
operation," crowding, contacts,
compromised skin, they bite
each other, they get abrasion
from the fencing, contaminated
items and surfaces.
I'd say pig poop by
definition is sort of,
you know, a lack of cleanliness.
So it's no wonder that we've
seen the emergence just
in the past decade or
more of something called
"livestock-associated MRSA."
So new strains of MRSA
directly traceable back
to livestock production,
and we call these "LA-MRSA."
So these disproportionately
affect farmers, farm workers,
veterinarians, and
actually the people who live
with those people as well.
So a few years ago,
we decided we wanted
to understand the origins
of pig MRSA.
So we collected MRSA strains as
MRSA -- this is sequence type 398.
This is just a geeky label that
people like me put on bacteria.
I'll talk more about
sequence types later.
But we collected all these, and
we collected them from people,
and from animals, and
those that were M R S A,
and those that were
susceptible to Methicillin,
and we sequenced the genomes
of nearly a hundred of these.
And then we drew an
evolutionary tree
to understand how they were
related to one another.
And so this was the tree.
I don't expect you guys
to really memorize this,
but each of these nodes -- sorry,
each of these little names,
the little digits at the
end is a little islet,
that is a different staph bacteria.
And then pink is from people --
sorry pink is from animals,
and gray is from people.
And you see that the pink
are all clustered up there.
It turns out that that's
the livestock lineage,
and these down here
are the older ones,
those are the livestock
independent lineages.
Those are the ones of people.
And so what we learned
from doing this was
that the livestock associated
with MRSA actually evolved
from staph and people.
So I have a cartoon version.
I think this is better.
Right; so Fisher-Price
is better even
for Nobel laureates,
they've told me.
All right; so it turns out we
have staph circulating in people.
Those people inadvertently
pass staph to the animals.
So -- well this is kind
of gross, but, you know,
farmer blow snot rockets.
Anyway, you can share
bacteria with your animals
from your nose, possibly.
And then where we're using
lots of antibiotics in animals,
we get this transition from M S S
A, so susceptible, to M R S A, MRSA.
And then that's spreading
now to back to people.
And this is a very
clear -- we have --
this epidemiology is very clear
now that this is happening.
What's also happening, and
I mentioned this before,
is that the people living with
these people are at very high risk
for picking these up as well.
But the story continues to evolve.
So we're studying this very
intensely in Northern Europe
where we have access to the animals,
to drug records, to everything,
whereas in the United States,
we get a shotgun in our face
when we try to go onto these farms.
But there we can study
these very clearly.
And we see now it's spilling
over into the general community.
It's usually the people
living near these farm workers
or around the farm, so it could
be environmental exposures,
or it could be secondary
exposure to these people.
We've seen outbreaks in hospitals
that are clearly the
livestock strains.
And it's from these people going
into the hospital and then a mistake
with the hand hygiene, probably, and
they pass it onto other patients.
And then we now we see
for the first time,
we just published this two weeks ago
in the Clinical Infectious Diseases,
a really important journal in
my field that there's evidence
of food-borne transmission too.
And this is this first
time that we've seen this.
So this is continuing to evolve.
We see that the DNA of
these bacteria are changing,
and they appear to becoming -- some
strains are becoming adapted back
to humans, and so they could
spread better among humans.
And so we're keeping
our eye on this,
and we're using these DNA
technologies to keep watching it.
It's now become a textbook
example, though.
So this is just my little
cue to remind me to say this.
This is a textbook example of what
happens when you use antibiotics
in the livestock production,
what can happen to people.
And so when I went to -- I spoke
at the CDC back in January,
and I was just, you know, going over
my slides and I put this slide in.
And I said, "I should just
double-check that they still have
that up on their website."
And I went there and they'd
modified it and they added this.
So they added, "And areas where
animal handling is common,
such as a veterinary clinics
and livestock settings."
So they saw our paper, I guess,
and many, many other papers coming
out on livestock associated MRSA,
and they modified their website.
The CDC is -- these
are real scientists,
and they are an amazing group
of people really looking
out for our health, and I
thought this was very cool.
Okay; I'm switching to E. Coli now.
So staph is the one that lives
on our skin and our noses.
E. Coli lives in your gut.
And E. Coli has a lot
of personalities.
Right; there are thousands
of strains of E. Coli.
But from a clinical
perspective, there's three;
there's the good, the
bad, and the ugly.
So the good is the kind that about
30% of us carry in our gut now.
It's just part of our microbiome,
probably just helping
us with digestion.
The bad is the kind that like
the Jack-in-the-box E. Coli
from the early '90s, right, so
these dramatic food borne outbreaks.
Jack-in-the-Box responded very well
and helped have something called
"HACP, which is "hazard
analysis and control points."
So this really revolutionized
food safety in the United States.
But we still have these
outbreaks of the bad E. Coli,
the diarrhea-causing E. Coli.
And about 52 to 100 people die
of that E. Coli each year
in the United States.
But the ugly, the really, really
bad one, or super-bad as I
like to say sometimes, is the kind
that causes urinary
tract infections.
And this one kills about 36,000
or 40,000 people each
year in the United States.
So let me tell you a
little bit about expac,
extra-intestinal pathogenic E. Coli.
Has special features; it
has attachment factors.
It has these little
hooks on its surfaces
to attach to your urethral cells.
It can cloak itself
from the immune system.
So it can hide itself
from the immune cells
that want to gobble it up.
It can produce toxins.
It can acquire iron.
It can survive.
It can deal with uric acid.
So it can deal with the harsh
environment of the bladder.
And it causes six to eight
million bladder infections
in the United States each year,
a quarter million kidney
infections, at least.
I think this is an underestimate,
and these numbers are getting old.
These are 2006 numbers.
And also deadly blood infections.
So as I said before, about
36,000 to 40,000 deaths in 2006.
The number's almost
certainly higher today.
And antibiotics are critical to
prevent this ascent from the bladder
into the kidneys, and then into
the blood where it kills you.
And so antibiotic resistance
is a major challenge
when it comes to expac.
So I want to lock in
this relationship,
because not many people
-- I didn't know this
until I met this guy named Jim
Johnson, a wonderful professor
at the University of Minnesota.
And he's like, "Lance, you
need to be looking at E. Coli,
because E. Coli causes all
these bladder infections."
It turns out it kills
-- it causes 80
to 85 percent of bladder infections.
So E. Coli is the main
neuropathogen.
The gut is the immediate reservoir.
So it's really E. Coli getting from
the gut into the urinary tract.
I'd love to talk for a while
about how that happens,
but I mean there are lots
of ways that happens.
Sex is one way; the
best way, I think.
So it's much better than riding a
bike with dirty underwear, I think.
[Laughter] And then so
understanding that it's the bacteria
in the gut getting
into the urinary tract.
And women -- I won't
ask for a show of hands,
but women are at a much greater
risk for urinary tract infections,
at least until we get into our 70s.
So understanding how
these things then get
into our guy is really important.
And I, along with a number
of people, are real pioneers
in this field have been asking
this question, "Is it possible
that food-borne bacteria,
E. Coli are causing the
urinary tract infections?"
So this guy, Lee Riley, in the
middle was the first one working
with Amy Mangus, on the end
there, to ask this question.
They recognized these outbreaks
of urinary tract infections
and they said, "This looks
like a food-borne outbreak."
But they were still dancing
around this a little bit,
and it's really the genomic methods.
And I'm going to tell you a
little bit about what we're doing
to really resolve this issue.
That's Jim Johnson
between Amy and Lee,
and this is Neal Molar
[phonetic] from Denmark
who also does really
wonderful work on this.
And they're all friends
and collaborators.
So in 2012 -- actually 2011,
I had this idea that I want
to do this study to understand
this, to quantify this,
and to prove whether it
does or does not happen.
And so I was living in Flagstaff.
That's where one of
my labs is in Arizona.
And it's a small
geographically-isolated city,
and we said, "Let's go
to every grocery store
in the town twice per month and
buy every brand of chicken, turkey,
and pork, and let's team up at
the hospital, where my friend,
my good old classmate, runs
the infectious program --
or the infectious disease program,
and let's collect every E. Coli
from every urinary tract infection
and blood infection over the course
of a year the same
year, in the same town,
and let's see if we can resolve
how much overlap there is."
And so we did that.
And at the end of the year, we'd
sample nearly 2500 meat product,
and we got almost 1300
urinary tract infections
from Flagstaff Medical Center.
So this is what we found
in the meat supply.
It turns out most of
the meat that we tested,
81% on average was
contaminated with E. Coli.
No surprise, E. Coli is an
indicator of fecal contamination.
You have feces in your meat.
[Laughs] Sorry.
Sorry, cook it, wash your hands.
But nearly 90% of the
poultry products
that we tested were contaminated
with E. Coli, and 60% of pork.
All right; we looked at then
what were these resistant to?
They were resistant to lots
of different antibiotics.
And so the blue line, the
blue column is from chicken.
So this are the E.
Coli from chicken.
Each of these three-letter
codes is a different antibiotic.
And the percent is the percent
of the E. Coli that we tested
that was resistant to these
different antibiotics.
And what you see, you will notice
that turkey is off-scale, right?
Why is that?
Well, I would guess that it's
because they're using
more antibiotics
than these other commodity
producers.
But in the United States,
we don't have the right
to know what antibiotics are
being used in which animals,
because that's a trade secret.
Antibiotic use in animal
production is a secret.
It's their secret for making
cheap meat for you guys.
Now, don't have that sour look.
The one place where gentamicin is --
the one place where chicken beats
turkey is actually gentamicin.
And that's because it's legal to
inject chicken eggs with gentamicin
in the United States, to prevent
infections from possibly occurring.
So we have these machines, we have
machines that injects pallets full
of eggs simultaneously while
we're also administering vaccines.
Vaccines, I love; I
think that's a good idea.
Injecting antibiotics
into eggs, terrible idea.
And we did a study of people
who catch chickens for a living
and they had 32 times the risk
of carrying gentamicin resistant
E. Coli as their community peers.
So now we're asking are
these bacteria related?
So we have 1900 -- or nearly
2,000 E. Coli from the meat.
So 81% of all those products that we
tested, we got E. Coli from there.
And then we have E. Coli from
urine and blood in the hospital.
And now what are we going to do,
we're going to sequence
all those genomes.
I told you it got really
cheap, right?
And we have a million dollar grant.
We spent it in two years.
We had a million dollar
grant to do this.
And so we sequenced all
of those genomes using one
of these next generation sequencers.
So we have a three-step approach.
And this is kind of wonky, so
just roll with me for a minute.
I'll boil it back down
with Fisher-Price,
or I'll at least try
to be simple about it.
So what we do is we
sequence the genomes,
and then we do a low-resolution
genotype,
so using a standard method called
multi-locus sequence typing.
Doesn't matter.
But we assign them to a sequence
type so we can group them together.
And then we use the whole
genome to understand
to make one of those family trees.
If we try to do them altogether,
we lose resolution actually,
so this is the way that we do it.
We group them, then
we make a family tree.
We group them, we make
a family tree.
And we ask at a very high resolution
with the best resolution
you could ever hope
to have using the whole genome
sequence, "How are these related
to one another, what we see in the
food and what we see in the people
in the same city, over the
same course of the year?"
Okay; so here's the first thing.
So this is just that
initial grouping
and how they're related
to one another.
This is really cool.
So the size of the bubble is --
sorry, the number is the sequence
type, so that's the DNA fingerprint.
It doesn't matter, just like
-- consider it like a name,
Fred, Jane, Larry, whatever.
So and then the size of the
bubble means that there were more
of the E. Coli with that name.
So sequence slide 131 is one
of the most important E.
Coli-causing urinary tract
infections in the United States
today; actually, globally.
And we did a study where we showed
it's a brand-new strain that's gone
pandemic in a very short time.
And then if it's yellow, it's urine.
If it's red, it's meat.
And that's not by accident.
Right; so meat is red,
yellow is urine.
And then if you have a
little line connecting them,
they're related to one another.
And I think what you can see is
that you've got your reds
all clumping together,
and you've got your
golds clumping together.
So these are all related together
to one another at some level.
But what you see is you have
Pac Man-shaped bubbles, right?
So some -- you see these red pie
pieces in the gold bubbles, right,
the yellow -- urine yellow bubbles.
And you see yellow pie pieces
in the meat red bubbles, right,
suggesting population overlap there.
And but at this level, this is
low-resolution so we can't say
with confidence that yes, meat
was the source of that infection
from 117, or those 131 infections.
We can't say that meat
was definitely a source.
But what we can do is we can
take these little bubbles,
and we can draw that
high-resolution tree,
and we can actually look
at it in great detail.
I hope you guys can see the color.
Can you see that there's
red and black?
So black is from a urinary tract
infection, red is from meat.
So sticking -- gold
won't show up, right,
so I had to stick with
black for this one.
All right; what you see is you
have two different lineages.
They're distinct, right?
So we would call none of these
urinary tract infections.
We're not going to call
any of these food-borne.
We're using a very conservative
view of this, and we're saying,
"These are two separate
lineages; they're unrelated."
So let me show you another one.
There's ST-58, so that's
the name of that one.
Let's draw a tree with that one.
You see that the urinary
tract infections,
the islet of the black ones are
nested all throughout the red.
They all share common
ancestors with the food,
and those are very short branches.
That means that they all came from
the same population very recently.
And so these are food-borne
urinary tract infections.
So we do that with each of these
bubbles; we go through each one.
SC 95 looks promising, right,
it looks like there can
be some overlap there.
But it turns out that --
and I know you can't --
I realize now that you
can't see the color,
but the only red you see
is up there all by itself.
And so we're going to conservatively
say that these are unrelated.
It's possible that they are
related, but we're going
to be very conservative
for this first round
of estimating how many urinary tract
infections are coming from food.
Because I can tell you, there's
an industry that does not want any
of these to be food borne.
So very conservatively,
the blue circles --
and those were supposed to be
hidden until right now, surprise,
but it didn't work; the blue circles
represent all of those bubbles
where we have very clear, very
close high-resolution relationships.
So each of those represents
food-borne transmission;
in our opinion, my
opinion and my colleagues.
So today -- now these
numbers are not final.
If you are the media, I
wouldn't show you these data yet,
but this is our most conservative
estimate, that nine percent
of the urinary tract infections
in Flagstaff, Arizona --
and Flagstaff, Arizona is very
representative of the rest
of the country, because all the
meat that we produce is produced
in these local areas and then
distributed throughout the country.
So nine percent is our
very conservative estimate,
and it may be as high as 12-plus.
When we loosen up our -- yes when
we loosen it up, it's 12-plus.
So we're talking about -- now
if you scale that to the rest
of the country, we're talking about
over half a million infections --
at our -- at the most conservative
estimate, half a million
to 700,000 infections that we
had no idea were food borne.
So this represents a
totally different paradigm,
and a new conduit for
resistance genes from --
a newly-recognized conduit
of resistance genes
from animals to people.
And I can tell you, the other
thing that we haven't even looked
at is the resistance genes
moving independently,
which is another thing
we have to look at.
So I just want to stop here
for a second, and, you know,
I always see confusion when I talk
about food-borne urinary
tract infections.
So what happens is that
you mishandle the poultry,
or you consume undercooked
poultry or some other meat,
and you consume the E. Coli, it
gets in your gut, and it grows there
for a little while and then it
makes the short trip from --
sorry to be graphic, from
your anus to your urethra,
and you have a bladder
infection from food.
Okay; does that make sense?
So we coin this term "food-borne
urinary tract infections."
I like to call them "foodies,"
foodies against foodies.
And this is truly a paradigm
shift in what is a food borne,
or a food-associated infection.
Right; it's no longer --
sorry I'm a microbiologist;
it's no longer diarrhea
and vomiting, right?
Now it can be MRSA infection, it can
be an untreatable bladder infection.
And it gives us new context
for those 34 million pounds
of antibiotics that we use in
the United States each year.
But we are not alone, right, and
we've distributed this model,
we've shown this model of industrial
animal production to the world.
And the world is changing
their consumption habits.
So the BRICS nations, Brazil,
Russian, India, China, South Africa,
these countries are
developing very quickly,
and they're adopting
our meat-centric diet,
and they're adopting our
methods of producing animals
in these industrialized system
using lots of different antibiotics.
And this is a global challenge
that we all have to meet.
And the problem is that we
don't have a box to stand on,
because we've been doing it.
We designed the system,
and we really haven't
changed much over the years.
And my birthday is November 19th; I
don't know if you can see the date,
but November 19th this
hit the media cycle.
So new mobile resistance element
was found in animals and people.
So it turns out that China
had adopted our methods
of using antibiotics in
food animal production.
They were using our last
drug, a drug called Colastin,
our last drug for treating CRE,
carbapenem-resistant
enterobacteriaceae,
that's super E. Coli,
super-resistant E. Coli
and its cousins to
klebsiella and those guys.
They were using that drug to
raise animals using our model;
because it was an old drug,
nobody cared about it until we ran
out of drugs and we got desperate
and we started using colistin.
And then all of the sudden,
we realized that this
new gene had evolved.
We'd never seen it before.
It was a mobile piece of DNA,
a piece of DNA that's
very readily transmissible
between different strains
of E. Coli and klebsiella.
And so this just hit my
field like a ton of bricks.
And in the weeks that
followed, we had my colleagues
around the world started
scanning their databases of DNA
and I said, "Hey, it's here already.
Hey, it's over here already."
The highest concentration
that we've seen is in China
where they were doing this.
But we found it now it's already
in the United States as well.
And that's that last -- this is
the last card for that royal flush.
So for CRE, some strains of
CRE are just missing one gene,
and this is it, to be untreatable.
And so now we're talking about
untreatable bacteria on meat.
But we don't even recognize
this kind
of E. Coli is food-borne pathogens.
So how do we regulate that?
How do we say we don't
want your product?
And how do we respond to
China and other countries
that are using our last drugs
for food animal production,
or any drugs, you know, in an
abusive fashion, how do we respond
to them when we do the same
thing in the United States?
It's really difficult.
So I'm just wrapping up.
I just have a couple of final
thoughts, and then we can talk.
The flyer said, "Antibiotics,
good or bad?"
Antibiotics, good.
I mean, antibiotics have
saved countless lives
since their discovery,
since Alexander Fleming accidentally
discovered penicillin in the 1930s,
and they were introduced
to human medicine.
Yes; they have a profound effect
on our microbiome, that is,
the community of bacteria
that we actually are,
you know, dependent on.
But our microbiomes generally
recover from those temporary things,
and these antibiotics save us from
the immediate, the acute infection
that we're suffering from.
Someday we might have
something better
that specifically kills
just the bad bacteria
and leaves the good bacteria
intact, and those are some
of the things we're
trying to work on at GW.
But for now, this is the
best thing that we have,
and we should really protect them.
And then the other
thing I want to say is
that sick animals need antibiotics.
So I don't want anybody to walk out
of here thinking that I'm saying
that we shouldn't treat sick
animals with antibiotics.
We should.
But if we have a system that
makes animals sick by design,
that system's broken and we
have to change that system.
And we may not have to go
to something as radical
as free-ranging happy little pigs,
but we should be raising them
in a way that doesn't
make them sick repeatedly.
I mean, if you can predict it
based on a clock or a calendar
that they're going to get sick
and you have to have antibiotics,
that system's broken, in my opinion.
And the last thing I want to
end with is a message of hope.
I don't think that the
post-antibiotic era is inevitable.
I mean, some people
have already reached it,
23,000 Americans die
each year, right,
but this time when
there's just no antibiotics
at work, that's not inevitable.
I just came back from Scandinavia.
They really control
antibiotics in animals,
they really control
antibiotics in human medicine,
and have really good
hygiene in the hospitals,
and they have really low
drug resistance rates.
And the people who have
drug-resistant infections are often
returning from travel, or have
consumed imported meat products.
So there is hope, but we
have to do this globally.
And I do think we can do it.
So just -- none of you guys
care about this, but this is --
science takes massive teamwork.
I have computer scientists, I have
clinical research coordinators,
I have clinicians, I
have lab technicians,
I have very dedicated
people that work with me,
and I appreciate them all.
So I can just go out and talk about
it and draw Fisher-Price characters.
So with that, I'll stop.
Thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> Tomoko Steen: [Inaudible]
questions?
>> Lance Price: Yes; I'm
very happy to take questions.
I'll stay as long as you want.
>> Tomoko Steen: Could
you repeat the questions?
>> Lance Price: Yes.
>> Tomoko Steen: Any questions?
>> [Inaudible], how do
antibiotics kill bacteria?
>> Lance Price: So how do
There are a lot of different
molecular mechanisms,
but on a very high level, they
either block DNA synthesis,
RNA synthesis, so that's DNA
goes to RNA goes to proteins.
They block protein synthesis,
or they block the cell walls
that the bacteria need to
hold themselves together.
So they're just blocking
the essential steps
of making a bacteria.
Yes.
>> Tomoko Steen: Other question?
>> So how do you [inaudible]
hospitals
and when doctors prescribe
antibiotics,
they gave the suggestion
of [inaudible],
and what reference do they have to
make those suggestions to patients?
>> Lance Price: So your
question is, "One of the things
that doctors say is that you
should take an antibiotic
for a specific period,
and only for that period?"
[ Inaudible Comment ]
Lance Price: Yes; so I think
that that's something they're
really trying to dial in.
I mean, it's not a perfect science
yet, like how long do you take them,
and how much do you take?
Right; so it's really adjusted for
body mass size, and you've noticed
in the United States that body
masses are changing, right?
And but what we're learning is that
-- or what some drugs we're learning
that you can cut back the amount
of time that people are on,
so that you reduce that pressure
on all the bacteria in the person.
Right; so you can dial that back.
But you should do it for -- you
should take them for as long
as the doctor says you should
take them, and let them figure
out what that time should be.
But right now, you know, if they
say ten days, take it for ten days;
if they say three days,
take it for three days.
Did I answer your question?
>> Right. I just think maybe
it's not optimized in regards
to being treated ended up
unnecessarily so that overdose
of any kind actually helped
to, you know, [inaudible].
>> Lance Price: Right;
so I agree both dosing
and who gets antibiotics
is not optimized.
Right; so people are --
doctors often prescribe what
we called "empirically," right?
So somebody comes in and they
have some symptoms that could be
or could not be bacterial
infections, but they don't have time
to like collect the culture,
and wait for the culture,
or they don't think they have time
to do this, collect the culture,
wait for the culture to come
back, check those records,
and then make a reactive
recommendation.
And so they just guess and they
say, "Ah, you probably have E. Coli
in your bladder, and it's
probably susceptible to this.
Here's a prescription.
Get out of here."
And so what we really want to do
is move towards a rapid molecular
diagnostics so they can
collect the pee in the office,
and within 15 minutes know
exactly what you're infected with,
what it's susceptible to, and
give you the exact antibiotics
that you should have
for the exact duration.
And I think we'll be there
in a few years, actually.
Yes. I mean, the molecular
techniques are out there.
Yes. You had a question back there.
Yes?
>> Yes; [inaudible] so
what is your recommendation
for staying clear of [inaudible] --
>> Lance Price: What should you
do; is that what you're -- [laughs]
>> Yes; should we go organic,
should we give up eating?
I mean, what is your [inaudible]?
>> Lance Price: So I'd
be a hypocrite to say
that you should give up meat,
although it is a healthy choice.
I'm not a vegan or a vegetarian.
But that is one way to avoid food
borne drug-resistant bacteria.
The other part of this, though, is
that nine billion animals make a lot
of poop, and that poop is
used as fertilizer on crops
where they grow vegetables
that vegetarians eat.
Right; so this is an
ecological problem.
So we don't -- you know, consumer
choice helps, but we really --
you know, we need to tackle
this as a global community.
But yes so what I do is
personally is I only buy products
that are raised from animals
raised with that antibiotic,
so I look for that label.
That's the only label
that really matters there.
Or organic is also a
label that indicates
that they have not been
treated with antibiotics.
And then there's a new label that's
coming out that's responsibly used.
What's the actual term -- anyway
there's a responsible use term
that they're working on
now, and that has to be --
we're really pushing for that
to be only third-party verified.
So it has the be the USDA verifying
that they're actually
using them responsibly,
which would only be
to treat sick animals.
And so we need -- I'm really leery
of this, but I do think that we need
to get there eventually is allowing
for the treatment of sick animals
and still selling that, you
know, with a specific label.
But it has to be third-party
verified.
We can't count on companies
to make that designation.
>> Right; I was told that organic --
there are certain levels of organic,
so they still use antibiotics,
or some type of hormones,
just not as many.
>> Lance Price: Not with organic;
organics is a very tight label.
That's a meaning -- natural
is just complete garbage.
So natural is the one
you're probably thinking of.
That just means there's no
plastic in there, you know?
[Laughter] You know, I mean, so yes.
Yes, and then -- yes.
>> Is there any significant
legislation
from [inaudible] try to
address these issues?
And if you were to impose new
legislation today to [inaudible],
what would be the key [inaudible]?
>> Lance Price: Right; Louise
Slaughter is our only microbiologist
in Congress, and she has
repeatedly put forth legislation
to reduce antibiotic use in animal
production to only therapeutic use,
and bring all antibiotic use
under control of the veterinarian.
And that has been received
almost as if you were proposing
to require all schoolboy -- all
male children in school wear skirts.
It's somehow just super-radical that
you would only allow antibiotics
to be used for sick animals.
So Louise Slaughter's bill,
it never gets voted on.
But that -- it's a great bill,
PAMTA, Preservation of Antibiotics
for Medical Treatment Act.
And I can't remember the
name of the Senate side bill.
But I think with more and
more companies coming onboard
with saying -- you know, like, big
companies like McDonald's and Tyson,
and big producers saying,
"Hey, we're going to get rid
of non-therapeutic biotics, at least
in poultry" it makes
it a safer environments
for Congress to kind of step in.
And so we're hoping that a bill like
that might gain momentum someday,
and God Bless Louise Slaughter.
[ Inaudible Comment ]
What's that?
>> What was the name,
one more time, PAMTA?
>> Lance Price: PAMTA,
Preservation of Antibiotics
for Medical Treatment Act.
And I really like that.
There's also star legislation --
I don't know if that one's
still getting introduced,
but that was something that Stuart
Levy was a real champion of,
which is just real
monitoring of antibiotics
and antibiotic resistance.
And that's one of the things
that we need, we need data.
I mean, it's ridiculous
that antibiotic use can be
considered a trade secret.
It is a shared resource that
needs to be productive by all
of us, and it's just a shame.
>> Thank you.
And FDA has done some
things, but not enough.
>> I heard that the bacteria
in pork is very hard to kill.
Even if you cook the pork well done,
the bacteria is still not killed.
I mean, that is -- I
heard from [inaudible],
and she said that's
why we don't eat pork,
[laughter] because it's still the
same, and I heard it from somebody
who is doing research, and I ate it.
So I don't know whether
that is true.
To me, bacteria is
bacteria, and you kill them
at the same temperature
wherever they are, right?
>> Lance Price: Yes; there can
be a little bit of variation
in thermo-stability,
but I'm with you.
Most it is very killable
with cooking
and a well-done pork chop
is not a risk factor.
It's handling that raw pork chop
that you bring into your house.
And there used to be
something called "trichinosis,"
and there still is trichinosis that
you can get from undercooked pork.
But in the United States,
it's largely absent
from our pork production, and
that's not even a bacteria,
and that's a parasite.
So we've seen some -- there are some
strains of E. Coli, for instance,
that are a little more heat-stable,
but nothing that could put
up with a good grilling.
Yes. Do I need to shut up or -- yes.
[ Inaudible Comment ]
>> I've got a question
regarding like hand washing
and antibacterial soap,
wasn't that recently sort
of [inaudible] scaling
back the use of it?
>> Lance Price: Right.
>> How does that kind
of affect [inaudible] --
>> Lance Price: Yes; so there's
something called "triclosan,"
and "triclocarban" that
they put into soaps.
These are antimicrobials
that they put into soaps.
And, you know, it never
really -- it was never --
triclosan soaps were never really
any better than regular soap.
I mean, it's the physical
action in these little bubbles
that actually take the
bacteria off your hands
and flush them down the sink, right?
And but the problem is that those
drugs can in the environment select
for drug-resistant bacteria.
But they can also produce these
stable toxic compounds that look
like dioxin in the environment.
And so it was never a good idea,
it was just always a sales gimmick.
And so I understand that
they're trying to ban that now,
and it couldn't be sooner.
Yes.
>> Tomoko Steen: Okay.
Please join me in thanking
Dr. Price.
>> Lance Price: Oh, thank you.
Thank you.
[Applause]
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.